[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact ladies have you
ever wondered why a man sometimes
doesn't seem to hear or understand what
you said well a study at the University
of Sheffield and published in the nero
image journal may provide the answer
these researchers found differences in
the way that male and female brains
process voice sounds the results of this
study demonstrate that a man processes
the sound of a male and female voice
differently in different regions of the
brain the guy's could easily hear and
understand other men's voices however
women have a greater natural singsong
melody in their voice using higher and
more complex range of sound frequencies
than a male voice
the study found that men had a harder
time deciphering the woman's voice and
really hearing what they were saying to
interpret a woman's voice a man has to
use a different region of the brain and
a more complex process that typically
analyzes music what's worse this process
may grow more difficult as men age so
when listening to a woman's voice a man
must make a little extra effort to
concentrate on what he's hearing if he
can't or won't then I guess at least he
has a better excuse for selective
hearing you know in the Bible God's
prophets often spoke about the
reluctance of men and women to hear the
voice of God stay with his friends were
going to learn more on this edition of
Bible answers live
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 six three
seven two nine seven we are live give us
a call with your Bible questions my name
is Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross good evening
friends and pastor Doug let's start the
program with prayer dear father we thank
you that we have this opportunity once
again to open up your word and study
together and Lord whenever we come to
the Word of God we need your guidance so
we do ask for the Holy Spirit to be with
us here in the studio be with our
friends who are listening
just all across the country and around
the world and we pray that we might
learn together before we ask this in
Jesus name Amen amen
well fasted are you open but with an
amazing fact but I guess it's not that
amazing to most woman yeah that main
don't always hear them right that's
right you know maybe this is a good time
for me to give a shout out to my wife
who is driving cross-country she said
she's gonna be tuning in via satellite
radio
karen is driving our youngest son back
to college and I said make sure and tune
in dear
now you understand why
sometimes I I don't hear you it's not my
fault it's just the way our brains
process that's a good excuse I'm going
to use that as long as I can
there evidently is a difference I don't
know if why you know there's a reason
why God wired men differently you know
typically men are more task oriented men
or women or more relationship oriented
and I'm gonna ask the Lord when I get to
heaven why was it harder for us to hear
women's voices so that'll be I'm sure
there's a reason for it but it made me
think about all the places in the Bible
where the Lord speaks to his people and
they don't seem to listen you know in
the book of Revelation he says what 7
times I think in Revelation 2 and 3 he
that has an ear let him hear what the
Spirit says to the church now the only
reason he would say he that has an ear
well that's everyone let him hear
because they're not listening in Matthew
13 15 jesus said for the hearts of this
people have grown dull and their ears
are hard of hearing and their eyes they
have closed lest they should see with
their eyes and hear with their ears and
understand with their hearts and turn
that I should heal him and Zechariah 7
11 but they refused to heed they
shrugged their shoulders and stopped
their ears so they could not hear and I
think there's a place in now is it
Psalms where David says whoever turns
away his ear from hearing the law even
as prayer is an abomination or that
maybe proverbs actually you know through
the Bible you'll see this kind of
language is used where it seems like
people have selective hearing when it
comes to listening to the voice of God
the verse you referring to their pastor
died his proverbs chapter 28 verse 9
when somebody turns away from hearing
the law their prayer is an abomination
you know we have a free offer that deals
with the subject of how do we respond
when we hear something from the Word of
God do we receive it do we accept it or
do we close eye years to it it's called
hidden eyes and closed ears that's the
name of the book
well they happy to send this to anyone
who calls and asks and the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven that is our
resource line just
for the book it's a free offer this
evening hidden eyes and closed years you
know there are many times in the Bible
pastime where God gave a special message
of warning to people or a special
invitation as in the case of Jesus
calling people to repentance
unfortunately most of those who heard
the message turned away from it they
didn't respond to it and you know we
don't want to do the same thing today
God is still calling people through his
word we want to respond to that there's
always a blessing and doing what God
says so well be able to send this book
to anyone who calls and asks it's called
hidden eyes and closed ears the number
to call he's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven that is the
resource phone line and if you have a
Bible question we have some phone lines
open this is a good time to call the
number is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven again that number is 804 63
72 97 and if you call now there's a very
good chance we're gonna be able to get
you on the program
after a few moments well we're ready got
our first caller this evening we have
Curtis that's listening in looks like
New Mexico Curtis welcome to the program
yes hello fellows hi um I was curious if
if you could tell me from from what's in
the Bible if it if if you're supposed to
be buried or if it's okay to be cremated
alright great question we get this
periodically because if the Lord tarries
everybody at some point is gonna have to
make a decision about that and it is
very expensive these days to perform a
traditional burial even cremation is
expensive what does the Bible say about
that
well you don't find any explicit command
in the Bible that says you shall not
cremate or that you must do a
traditional burial first we need to just
back up and ask the question
whatever method is used in your death or
in dealing with your body you may have
been blown apart in a in a war you may
have drowned at sea and been there
gobbled up by the sea creatures you may
be cremated you might be buried
none of that prevents God from
resurrecting you with a new body
so first let's establish that
traditionally
in the Bible when someone died they were
given some basic embalming and burial
and the reason that the Church Fathers
say now this is not in the Bible this is
extra biblical reasoning the Church
Fathers would say that because man was
made in the image of God that even in
death that image should be respected of
course you want to respect the memory of
a person even though you know they're
gonna get a new body Pastor Ross and I
were at a funeral today and it's
something that you know we we all have
to address generally you go to Indian
some of the pagan count countries and
they often burn a cremate you know they
feel like they're accelerating things to
go on with reincarnation in the circle
of life but when you think about it if a
person's buried and the Bible says ashes
to ashes and dust to dust
sometimes the cremation is just
accelerating the process so we can't
give you a command from the Bible the
example if you're gonna go
circumstantially the example in the
Bible is burial there are two
individuals that we can think of in the
Bible that were burned and we know
they'll be resurrected that one being
Jonathan the son of Saul who was a good
friend of King David that that's about
the only thing I can think of someone
that was burned and you know part of the
reason that we see an example especially
in the early Christian church of burial
versus what the pagans are doing the
Christians wanted to make a statement of
their faith and their belief in a
resurrection when Jesus came the second
time the pagans didn't believe in a
resurrection and so when they burnt
their dead it was releasing the spirit
at least that's what they believed to
some kind of intermediate state whereas
the Christian believed that the dead
would be resurrected when Jesus comes
the second time and so it was an
evangelistic statement especially in
that pagan culture to bury the dead
versus follow this tradition of the day
things are little different specially in
you know North America might be
different in some other countries but
most Western countries there's not that
connection to cremation as the pagans
had right I hope that helps a little bit
Curtis
and we appreciate your question we do
have a study that will provide you for
free and it's on the subject of our the
dead really dead it just tells a little
bit about the state of man and death in
the resurrection yes the number to call
for that is eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and you can
ask for the study guide called are the
dead rarely dead thank you for your call
Curtis you're listening to Bible answers
live this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time call us at
[Music]
1-800-455-1052 or falling by baptism the
couple got married they got baptized
because they just learned the truth and
wanted to do the right thing I've seen
it done that way but then you know if
you're if you're believer and you're
going to a wedding where there's a lot
of partying that takes place afterward
at the reception which sometimes happens
at dancing and stuff like that it that
is not in keeping its difficult for a
Christian anytime but you know
especially the Sabbath I'd say it varies
with the event
and you know what the spiritual
atmosphere is gonna be okay how about a
baby shower for like a great grand baby
or a family reunion
yeah and you know I understand that
sometimes you know you've got
convictions about keeping the
commandments and the Sabbath and you go
you're invited to a family event where
they may not feel the same way I think
you need to just really pray for grace
and wisdom about you know can you be a
witness at this occasion I think that
people have to really pray that God's
Spirit Guides have been some of these
things okay yeah you just want to make
sure you keep the principles of the
Sabbath
yeah adding to that that principle of
the Sabbath of course there's nothing
wrong in getting together with family on
the Sabbath the Sabbath is a day for
yeah rest and communion and fellowship
and being together with family or being
at a special event that's that's the
contest if your family is all drinking
and watching the Super Bowl yeah if the
environment is opposed to that No you
know and then I know pass it up some
experiences where someone might pop in
and give their greetings or they wishes
or whatever the case might be and at
least show the issue the same or that
they don't participate don't stay for
the party part though what is the case
might that's a good idea yeah seen a
pastor Ross my pastor Ross he's a
pastor's kid and I am a pagans kid and
so our families were a little different
that's right yeah so when you say get
together with family you haven't seen my
family anyway all right here well thank
you very much Sue Ellen hope that helps
some thank you very much I appreciate
that information all right god bless the
next photo that we have is Craig
listening in Jackson Jackson Michigan as
well Craig welcome to the program well
thank you very much pastor Doug Pastor
John I have two quick questions and the
first one is are the 144,000 are they
the only ones that are still living at
the second coming that's the first
question and the second question was
carp
is that a clean fish to eat since it has
fins and scales and it's it's a bottom
feeder though so I was curious about
that
two very different questions 140 or 4000
and carp so hundred and forty-four well
yeah you know I just it's gonna be
difficult to segue from one end to the
other yeah but no I think it's funny the
144,000 are not the only ones living in
the last days the 144,000 is a special
group of spirit-filled leaders that do a
special work and if you read in Chapter
seven of Revelation it says that they're
you know twelve thousand from the twelve
tribes and this angel or an elder is
talking to John and he also sees a great
multitude that no man can number and
John asks who is this great multitude
arrayed in white robes and where they
come from and the elder says these are
they that came out of Great Tribulation
and they've washed their robes and made
them white in the blood of the Lamb
there's a great multitude that comes out
of tribulation some wonder is this the
final tribulation which would mean that
they're not the only ones in the last
days I don't think the hundred and forty
four thousand is the only group saved
because I did the math on a calculator
if there are roughly seven billion
people in the world today and only a
hundred and forty-four thousand are
saved your chances of being saved are 1
in 50,000 which is better than the
lottery but it's not it's kind of
discouraging well I was I was curious
more so on the are they the only ones
that are actually living at the second I
know that they're not the only one saved
but are they the only ones actually
living on earth at that time no because
there's even wicked that are alive on
earth when Jesus comes it says the
wicked run from the presence of his
coming so you've got a lot of people
alive on the earth you've got a large
group of saved there's I think there's a
large group converted from the hundred
and forty-four thousand I will send you
a book on that will tell you about in a
minute and just quickly on carpet did
you look him up you know I was looking
it up and they didn't give me an answer
well if Bible says if it has fins and
scales it's clean unfortunately I don't
know that much about fish pastor that
guy yeah I've never fishes that I know I
don't need fish either I used to but as
far as I know if it's got fins and
scales it's clean yeah I wouldn't want
to eat anything that's a bottom-feeder
yeah that's yes currently
bottom feeder and I was curious about I
get that question sometimes from people
that I talk to you about Leviticus and
the proper foods to eat and but they
keep coming back with it's a bottom
feeder and so I I I don't know what to
tell them
yeah if it according to the Bible if
it's got fins and scales it's
technically clean now when you say
scales if the only way you can see the
scale is through a microscope then maybe
you need to think twice about that fish
when when the biblical principles are
given it was a way in which the people
could distinguish between the clean and
clean fish by looking at it
so if it obviously has scales on the
fish then you know and fins then you
know it's clean if you can't see the
scales or if it's so small you need a
microscope then then you need to ask
yourself you know is this is this maybe
not a clean animal right okay well thank
you
thank you very much all right he thanks
a lot bye-bye I was just looking online
and said here that the carp are the pigs
of the river with fins so I don't think
I'd want to eat them okay Ruby is a next
cola from California Ruby walked in the
program not Ruby huh group say yeah I've
never talked on her operation before I
kind of shy but my question was in Jesus
when Jesus was crucified and resurrected
in 40 days on earth well when he got
resurrected by elsewhere resurrected
yeah there's one gospel that says that
when Jesus died on the cross that there
was a great earthquake in the midst of
that there was a lot of graves that were
opened and some of the saints that slept
came out of those graves following the
resurrection and appeared to others then
that would be in matthew 27:51
53 no in our lesson on the second coming
does a talk well rather the rest I'm
sorry the lesson on death does it talk
about that group I don't know I don't
know if it specifically mentions that
group now you might wonder what happened
to them after they were resurrected well
we
that they ascended with Jesus to heaven
and the verse for that is Ephesians
chapter 4 verse 8 where it says
therefore you say if when he ascended on
high he led captivity captive and gave
gifts to men so when Jesus sent it to
heaven those who were resurrected at the
time of his resurrection they came as
the firstfruits so to speak of the
resurrection of course the big
resurrection happens when Jesus comes
the second time well that was my portion
that you appreciate what you told me
because I was kind of curious about that
I've heard people talk about that I
wasn't really sure yep there's there's
one verse it's interesting that Matthew
is the only one who mentions a true band
but it's there you're right they there
is a group Deno amazing facts has a free
Bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of God's words sign up
today for this free Bible study course
by calling 184 for 257,000 that's one
eight four four two one five 7,000
all right Pastor Ross who do we have
next look at Kathleen listening in
Arizona Kathleen welcome to the program
hi there hi Pastor Ross hi pastor
bachelor hi my question is Isaiah 65 or
17 the last part of it where it says in
the former shall not be remembered or
come into mind now I know the thousand
years that were in heaven we're going to
understand why people don't make up
people that we may love you know we'll
understand why God is just but I'm
thinking this means when we get to the
new earth that we won't have any memory
of our past life here on this earth
because if we did even though I would
understand that my loved one that God
was being just I would still be sad you
know right you know I don't think that
Isaiah is saying here that God
brainwashes us so that we have no
recollection of our Redemption from this
life because I'm sure through eternity
we are going to have a memory of how
Jesus saved us and we'll never lose that
gratitude for that I think he's he's
principally talking about painful men
it's like heaven is gonna be so long
it's gonna be eternity and it's gonna be
so bright that you know you've heard the
expression time he'll go through a tough
experience but over time it gets easier
to bear and you don't think about it all
the time well think about if you live
for eternity a million years from now
how much are you thinking about the pain
and suffering in this world it's gonna
be totally eclipsed by the glory and
bliss and brightness of heaven so it
doesn't even come into mind see what I'm
saying yeah yeah I don't think that
right after the destruction of the world
in the resurrection suddenly were
brainwashed we don't remember anything I
think we're not gonna think on it we
won't be dwelling on those things
anymore there is a verse in first
Corinthians 13 where he says then I'll
know even as I am known so we're gonna
recognize and know each other up there
Jesus will have scars in his hands so
we'll know why the scars are there
because he had scars when he rose from
the dead but the painful memories will
not haunt us we won't be living with
regrets over our failures from this life
all right
okay thank you very much thank you
appreciate your call Kathleen and we do
have a free offer that talks about the
resurrection and the second coming of
Christ and it's called ultimate
deliverance and we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls and ask the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and again you can ask the study guide
it's called ultimate deliverance we'll
be happy to send that out to anyone who
calls and asks we've got Susie listening
in Colorado Susie welcome to the program
hi thanks for taking my call my question
is about the Ark of the Covenant I
understand that in the time of Jeremiah
that they hid it in a cave to protect it
from the Babylonians do you think that
that will be found before Jesus come
well I don't know some people have taken
the verse that's in where does it pass
trough revelation 11 where it says I saw
the temple of God open in heaven some
people have taken that passage where it
talks about I saw the temple open I saw
the Ark to mean that it's somehow going
to be found I don't find any explicit
prophecy that says it will be found it
would be great if it was I've thought
before even if Noah's Ark was found I
mean you know real tangible evidence
what would that do for Pete
faith in the Bible that'd be wonderful
that's what I was thinking it would be
wonderful if they saw those Ten
Commandments and maybe we're converted
over that but I don't find anything it
by what an opportunity yeah that'd be
such an opportunity to preach and
explain it all you know in a sense I
think Jesus said you believe because
you've seen blessed are those who
believe without seen we have the Ten
Commandments in our Bibles we don't have
the golden box we don't have the rocks
but we've got the we've got the words
that's right yeah so I don't know the
Lord may just say look I give them to
you you still have them it's you know he
doesn't want us to make an idol out of
the Ark he doesn't want us to pray to
any object who knows I don't know I'd
love for him to find it they're doing so
much digging around and building around
Jerusalem pastor Ross and I were there a
little more than a year ago that I
wouldn't be surprised if they dug up
some new things uh-huh yeah all right
well thank you so much thanks appreciate
it Susie all right next one of the B
heavies Karen listening in Florida Karen
welcome to the program we have just two
minutes before the break okay all right
well thank you Pastor Doug and Pastor
Ross for taking this question my
question is well it's for my son
actually Ethan he's 10 he's almost
anything he wants to know if God didn't
want Adam and Eve to eat from the tree
of knowledge of good and evil why did he
even create the tree well what I'd say
to Ethan is even though you're not
supposed to cross the street without
looking why is there a street I mean
sometimes we're surrounded with
opportunities in life to make bad
decisions and I think God wants us to
learn self-control and because the devil
had just rebelled God really was giving
Adam and Eve an opportunity to prove
their loyalty so they would never be
tempted again but they failed the test
so they had plenty to eat it's not like
God said be you've only got one tree to
eat from her two trees they had
thousands of trees eat from he said I'm
gonna give you one you're not supposed
to eat from and that was the one that
they got enticed to eat from because
they wanted to be like God they fell for
the same temptation as the devil okay
all right well I appreciate that he's
listening he's here you're on
speakerphone so he heard that question
he heard the answer has shell good
question Ethan and you know let me add
one other thought to that it's also note
that God limited the devil's access to
Adam and Eve to one tree so as long as
they stayed away from that tree they
were protected from the devil God didn't
allow the devil just to go harass them
or follow them around the garden so in
one way God limiting just to that tree
it was a protection for Adam and Eve so
they couldn't be tempted anywhere else
see I didn't know that part so that's
definitely something new so thank you
for adding that posture Oz and thank you
for you both so thank you again for
answering the question all right you
have a good evening
you too thank you so much we're gonna
have a break here in just a minute
friends before we rather than take
another call and have to cut them short
I just want to remind you that so much
of what you're hearing now you can also
peruse at the amazing facts website
amazing fact so RG don't go anywhere
we've got the best yet to come
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
four life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm or call one
eight hundred five three eight seven two
seven five one to know God's plan for
our world and solutions for your life's
challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more prefer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
calm or by calling 858 seven two seven
five written by the hand of God and
spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore com every bible
question you have answered moves you one
step closer to the fullness of god's
will for your life so what are you
waiting for get the answers you need for
a fuller richer more confident life
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
for one thing it stood the test of time
it's been the best seller for Oh 2000
years of you include the Old Testament
it's been twenty-five hundred
years more than that if you go to the
books of Moses almost 3000 yeah and then
you have the test of prophecy the Bible
has made a lot of very explicit
prophecies we know the prophecies were
written before the event took place you
know we know for instance from the Dead
Sea Scrolls that the prophecies of
Daniel and Isaiah were made before the
events and the prophecies came true very
explicit prophecies about what kingdoms
would rule the world and they did such
as Persia Greece and Rome but the Book
of Daniel is it was dated like by the -
200 BC I mean after the fact no well how
could the Book of Daniel be dated 200
years BC if the Dead Sea Scrolls have
the Book of Daniel in it and they've
dated those manuscripts a hundred years
before Christ by the link yeah I think
you're reading some books of what they
call higher criticism they're just
people that kind of criticize everything
but most historians believe that Daniel
because his knowledge of the Babylonian
and the Persian Court was extremely
precise the cities that he mentions the
language is part of Daniel is not only
written in Aramaic I think part of it is
written in Chaldean the Book of Daniel I
think is and you know if you believe
anything Jesus said Jesus quotes from
the Book of Daniel
so it had to be written before the time
of Christ that's one book but you know
you can go to other prophecies you can
go to prophecies of Moses where promises
prophesied that Jerusalem would be
besieged they would turn to cannibalism
they would be conquered by people that
came swooped down on him like an eagle
well the Roman armies their sign was an
eagle they besieged Jerusalem they
destroyed it and you know everything
Moses foretold happened just so many
prophecies that you can't deny you know
we may have lost that caller but
hopefully he's still listening hey if
you are still listening the best thing
you could do is we've got a study guide
will send you for free this is talking
to angel and it's is there anything left
you can trust and it talks about why we
know the bye
is trustworthy as the word of god okay
we'll be able to send that to you all
you need to do is call a resource line
that's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and the study guide
is called is there anything left we can
trust units 808 three five six seven
four seven and we're ready for our next
caller we've got Jeff is listening on
the road Jeff welcome to the program yes
how you doing we're doing okay thank you
for calling yeah thank you for accepting
my car I lost my daughter in the class
two months ago it's been eating me alive
that one
Jesse no he didn't have it if we
accepted Jesus I know I guess she know
me now well let's talk about it first of
all Jeff my heart goes out to you I lost
the son several years ago and I know
something about the heartache that
you're feeling you've got great comfort
you say that your daughter had accepted
Jesus and the promise is that when the
Lord descends from heaven let me give it
to you it's from first Thessalonians
chapter 4 that when the Lord descends
from heaven that the dead in Christ will
rise they get new glorified bodies and
that she is sleeping right now a
peaceful dreamless sleep that's why
Christians all over the world put the
words r.i.p on gravestones that means
rest in peace if a person dies saved
their next conscious thought is the
resurrection because they have no
consciousness of time so as far as your
daughter is concerned when she closed
her eyes in death the next thing she
knows is she's coming forth from the
grave in a glorious resurrection it's
it's like a moment for her Paul calls it
the twinkling of an eye but you and I
still live in this world of time the
second coming hasn't happened the
judgment hasn't happened the
resurrection hasn't happened those
things are future when we love someone
the Bible says you know to be absent
from the body is to be present with the
Lord if you die and you're saved you're
next conscious thought is the
resurrection of the righteous Jesus made
it clear that resurrection is in the
future
he said on the last day they will hear
his voice and come forth when Jesus
friend Lazarus died he said my friend
Lazarus sleeps and he's dead but I'm
going to wake him I hope that made sense
ain't you yeah so you don't have to
worry your your daughter is sleeping a
peaceful sweet dreamless sleep but for
her there's no consciousness of time her
next thought is gonna be almost
immediate a resurrection glorified body
in the presence of Jesus thank you so
much thank you
well thank you God lesson you know we
have a special lesson we'll send you on
that if you want more information or you
could even watch it or listen online and
just ask the study guide talking about
it's called other dead rarely dead and
it's actually a comforting truth this
past that I've mentioned the ones we
love who have trusted in Jesus and are
laid to rest they not looking down from
heaven seeing all the struggles that we
might be going through here on earth
they the next thing they know is when
Jesus comes they're resurrected and that
is indeed comforting just call and after
the study God is called other dead
rarely dead and the number to call is
883 five six seven four seven and we'll
be happy to send that to anyone who
calls and ask we also have a website
that we like to mention if you'd like to
learn more about the subject it's simply
called death truth com it's got a lot of
resources there what does the Bible
teach about the subject and those anyone
who looks at it I think you'll find it
comforting and encouraging
[Music]
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture the Egyptians built pyramids to
help guide the spirits of their leaders
Rome sanctioned holidays to honor and
appease the spirits of their dead even
the Bible tells of a king that used a
witch to contact the spirit of a
deceased prophet today ancient folklore
of spirits and apparitions have gone
from mere superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true
why do these stories persist does it
even matter we invite you to look inside
and find out for yourself visit death
truth calm next caller that we have is
Robert listening in Walla Walla
Washington Robert welcome to the program
hi Pastor oz hi pastor Doug hi Robert
thanks for calling you're welcome my
question tonight I guess you can see on
your screen is about the spirit
well not the spirit but yeah a spirit I
want you to define the word spirit like
when Jesus says says I commit my spirit
into your into your hands and then in
Hebrews of course it says that God is
the father of spirits usually we think
of spirit as being wrath but then is
Jesus saying I can commit my breath into
your hands or and is he the father of
breath or can you explain that yeah well
you're asking a good question of course
the word spirit in the Old Testament
comes from a Hebrew word hope I say this
right but I think it's Roloff it means
breath and it's you know it says God
breathed into Adam the breath of life it
sometimes translates the spirit of life
and he became a living being when you
get to the New Testament the word is
numa and that's where we get the word
like pneumatic tools are tools that are
driven by wind or air one of someone
catches a cold they deep in their lungs
they called it pneumonia NUMA meant
breath or wind it clearly sometimes the
word is talking about the inner life or
spirit of a person all the times it's
just talking about the breath of life
it's one of those words you need to read
the context to get the best definition
about how the writer is using the word
when Jesus is on the cross and he said
father into your hands I commend my
spirit
well the word is numa but he's talking
about the spirit of life that he's
putting into the father's hands his
you know is being I don't think it means
that Jesus was just saying here's my air
well I think sometimes breath in the
Bible is synonymous with life and you'll
find that you know when it talks about
breath was in him meaning his life was
in him so again it represents the life
of life yeah the breath of life yep does
that make sense what what about the
father of spirits no well there were and
which verse you referring to hebrews
hebrews 12 i'm gonna look it up here and
see if that word there is also numa if
it's the word pneuma then it's numa but
i would think that when he says the
father of spirits he's talking about the
father of he might be talking about we
talked about spirits in heavenly places
he's talking about angels usually in
that context Hebrews 12 9 yeah are you
struggling with that particular verse
are you what's your concern sometimes I
feel like I'm answering something you're
not asking well sometimes I talk to
these people who believe that we were we
were in heaven before we came to this
earth kind of thing and they say that
that's one of the verses that they use
father of spirits that sense he's the
father of spirits so we were born or we
were existed before we were born and
that kind of thing you know yeah well
I'm looking it up in in Hebrews chapter
12 verse 9 there again it is the word
with the pneuma root to it it means wind
breath life soul and of course you
needed to you want to do a full Bible
study on the subject of soul and spirit
and it's difficult to build a doctrine
on one verse you want to look at what
some of the other verses have to say
it's referring to life it's referring to
breath the essence of who a person might
be their character so those things also
need to consider when you look at these
words next caller that we have is Adrian
listening in Illinois Adrian welcome to
the program good thank you for calling
Adrian and your question tonight yes I
want to be sure I want to be brief
you know I'm listen I listen in during
my lifetime
numerous sermons about the pearl of
great price yes as it presented in the
gospel and the explanation was always
that the pearl is Jesus Christ is heaven
is the truth and so on last time I heard
recently the pastor was talking about
the same subject but presenting that the
pearl of the great rice is the sinner me
so I want to ask you if this is a sound
biblical explanation and stands for no I
think that Jesus says that the kingdom
of heaven is like a man seeking precious
pearls he finds one of great price and
he sells everything that he's got to
obtain the pearl Christ is comparing
that parable to other parables where he
said if anyone is going to come after me
he needs to forsake everything take up
his cross and follow me Jesus is telling
us in a number of places when you find a
treasure in a field you sell everything
you've got to get that treasure he says
seek and you'll find the thing we're
seeking for is not us the sinner we're
seeking for God the truth and the
salvation and Christ is saying that
eternal life is worth everything in this
world I could see where people would
spin it around and say well Jesus gave
everything to save us but that's really
not what Christ was saying in those two
parables of the treasure and the pearl
any thoughts on that pastor rod yeah
it's gonna echo what you were saying on
the first without a doubt the first
meaning of the parable is that when we
find salvation in Christ we're willing
to give anything and everything to
obtain it that is the pearl of great
price and then also it is true that
Jesus speaking of his mission said he
came to seek and save the Lost
and he gave everything everything yeah
and you know it's an incredible thought
why God would come to this earth to save
us and yet he sees value in us so I
could see how that could also be a
secondary application perhaps yeah both
gave everything well thank you
appreciate that
appreciate your question next folder
that we have is will go to ray listening
in Washington ray welcome to the program
a pastor Doug pastor Ross hi how can we
help you John 1:18 says that nobody has
ever seen God in other places it says
that also would you read Exodus 24 9 10
and 11 and then comment on it ya know
when first of all I think I know where
you're where you goin with this you're
wondering well the Bible says no man is
seeing God then why does it say that
these individuals saw God in the Old
Testament is that your question yes
that's my question yeah it's and it's
not just not just Moses you know Abraham
saw the Lord Jacob said I have seen God
Manoah and his wife they said we've seen
the Lord we're gonna die and she said
well if God wanted to kill us and why
would he reveal these things to us it
makes it clear when you look in John 6
46 it says not that anyone has seen the
Father except him who was from God he
has seen the father whenever people saw
God in the Old Testament it's what they
called a christophany it's when Jesus
God the Son appeared in his pre
incarnation glory now Daniel saw him in
vision he fell on his face Ezekiel saw
him and he cowered so there were a
number of prophets and patriarchs in the
Old Testament that saw some visit of God
they probably could not look into the
full unveiled face of even Christ in his
glory because Moses God told Moses look
no man's gonna see my face and live and
in our sinful condition to stare
undiminished into the face of God would
probably be presence of God is a
consuming fire the Bible says so I don't
know if that helps a little bit John 646
not that anyone has seen the father you
with me ray yes yeah yeah thank you very
much appreciate it all right he thinks
so much appreciate in you know I do have
a book that talks about the name of God
where I talked a little bit there about
these apparitions where they saw the
glory of God if you'd like to receive a
copy of the book called the mate the
name of God that I'm gonna call these
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and
as for the book called the name of God
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
calls and asks we've got let's see
Henry listening in Sacramento Henry
often to the program Henry in Sacramento
are you there
my name is mute on Henry going once
Henry twice he will come back we got
Joshua listening in Texas
Joshua Oh welcome to the program hey
how's it going thank you for having me
on the show good thanks for calling my
question was about in Matthew chapter 10
verse 23 when Christ is talking to his
disciples he says they won't be finished
spreading his gospel until the Son of
man has come in his glory but um
obviously the Son of man still hasn't
come yet so what does that mean and I've
known I've seen that in other parts in
other parts of the Gospels it marked on
Luke's so I was wondering what you guys
thought about it yeah this is a verse
where Jesus is sending out the apostles
and it says you'll be hated of all names
for my sake for surely I say to you that
you will not have gone through all the
cities of Israel before the Son of man
comes now when he's talking about going
through all the cities of Israel it is a
mysterious first some are wondering does
that mean the literal Israel is it
talking about all the cities that the
Israelites had established around the
Roman Empire is it talking about you
haven't gone around and talked to all
the spiritual Jews that I've called it's
a little bit of a mystery but obviously
the gospel has not been preached in all
the world yet yeah and remember there's
a lot of things that we find in Matthew
chapter 10 here and also echoed in
Matthew 24 not only related to the
second coming of Christ but a lot of
those also related to the judgment they
came upon Israel in the destruction of
Jerusalem in 70 AD some have discussed
the term they're the cities of Israel
has also been the cities where the Jews
were scattered throughout the Roman
Empire so it's not just limited
geographically to the Land of Israel but
the cities where the Jews had gathered
and of course you read about in the New
Testament of Acts Paul travelled to a
number of the cities and the group that
he would often preach to first were Jews
he would go to the synagogue so I've
seen some commentators address that
verse and saying not just the cities in
is
but also scattered throughout the Roman
Empire where the Jews well yeah I hope
that helps a little bit
Joshua yeah we're gonna try and get one
more call I think we got someone calling
from Indonesia pastor Ross line 12 there
yeah we got I think it's Rea listening
from Indonesia hello how are you thank
you so much for your time thank you well
we've got about five minutes yeah thank
you my question is in Genesis chapter
xxxi I think was a 439 438 and 459
yes all right can I read that to our
friends that are listening and then I'll
do my best you want me to try to explain
that yes I want your explanation English
all right no problem I'll do my best
now you read here in Genesis chapter 30
and I'll start with verse 37 now Jacob
took for himself the rods of green
poplar and he of the almond and the
chestnut trees and he peeled white
strips in them and exposed the white
which was under in the rods and the rod
said he appealed he set before the
flocks and the gutters in the watering
troughs where the flocks came to drink
so that they should conceive when they
came to drink so the flocks conceived
before the rods and the flocks brought
for a streaked speckled and spotted then
jacob separated the lambs now let me
tell you what's going on here friends
it's very interesting story jacob was
having problems taking care of his
father and lost sheep he finally told
his father-in-law look I'll take care of
your sheep for a few more years but we
got to have an agreement all of the
sheep and the goats that bear striped
speckled or spotted offspring are mine
his father-in-law said that's the deal
so when it came mating season and they
came to the watering troughs to water
and eat the grain that jacob took these
posts and he peeled the bark that
exposed white stripes and streaks that
were underneath the darker bark and he
put it before the animals so that when
the rams were going around servicing
they use somehow they would have this
visual of all these stripes and these
speckled poles and you know for years
people said well that was just a
superstition why did he do that well
they whatever reason they believed the
Shepherd's believe that maybe they'd get
more striped if they were looking on
stripes when they bred now we laugh at
that but I'll tell you they've had some
interesting studies why is it that
rabbits that live in the Arctic grow
white fur and the same hares
that live in the desert have brown fur
they can crossbreed and they have still
have hares and they've discovered that
animals are able to take in their
environment and transfer it into their
DNA somehow and they are able to
camouflage themselves or that they store
that visually and it does something to
their DNA that can actually affect the
offspring it's an amazing study I don't
know if it has to do with Jacobs story
here but you better be careful before
you discount that animals can actually
affect their offspring whether he was
following a superstition and God blessed
it or there was some scientific thing we
don't understand connected with it I
think the point is that God said look
I'm gonna give your your cattle spotted
and striped so that you'll become
wealthy with with cattle at work you got
a better answer about your you know I
think it was a common belief back then
that and maybe there was something to it
I am now we beginning to discover some
of these things with DNA and someone but
it wasn't belief back at that time that
the animals that were that they were
around the things that they were around
affected the type of offspring that the
animals would have that's why it says
Jacob separated the sheep so and the
goats from the others the spectral and
the Spotted from from the plain maybe it
will also an act of faith on Jacobs part
trusting that the Lord would indeed
bless him as he had said yeah that's out
of that that's true he's just saying you
know you I need Lord you know that I
need spotted and speckled if I'm going
to take care of my family it it is an
interesting story you know that's what I
love about the Bible is it puts it all
in there it helps us to understand that
it is the Word of God
well thank you very much for your
question Nara I hope that helps a little
bit that's the closest we can get to
what there there may be some scientific
connection why different animals
are able to transfer camouflage into
their DNA we're not exactly sure why are
the tiger-striped
and the Lions on the plains they're both
big cats why are the Tigers you know Joe
loves rice up in the snow country and
you've got the brown bear they needed
the white fur to sneak up on those seals
it's the Sun the Lord made them somehow
hey listening friends it won't be fair
for us to take another caller right now
I don't think we have enough time to do
it justice but please bear with me for
just a moment as I remind you lovingly
and pleadingly as I can that the only
reason you're hearing this program is
because there are people like you that
hear and say you know I want to bless
that program it's been a blessing to me
and keep them on the air you can just go
online and click on the amazing facts
website it's simply amazing facts and
dot o-r-g and it makes it very simple
anything you could give to keep us going
that's we live entirely 100% by the
support of our listeners our viewers the
people who read the literature and our
message is our mission I should say is
his message we're just our goal is to
get the Word of God out there we know
that the word has power to transform
hearts and we're trying to reach as many
hearts as we can so like that question
that came in tonight the gospel of the
kingdom Matthew 24:14 the gospel of the
kingdom will be preached in all the
world for a witness to all nations and
then the end will come that's when we'll
know we have gone over all the cities of
Israel when the gospel is preached in
all the world so that everybody around
the planet has a chance that's our
mission we're sending out the gospel
through radio television publishing live
evangelistic training internet and every
method we can thank you for tuning in
friends tell your friends and enemies
about the program and God willing we'll
study his word together again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
did you know that Noah was present to
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating zoo from the creation of the
world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
Bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the Bible and draw closer
to God's Word go deeper visit Bible
History com
what if you could know the future
what would you do what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past Alexander the Great becomes
king when he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy
a hundred and fifty years in advance
Cyrus had been named wrong was violent
they were ruthless they were determined
the Gospel writers see his death as a
fulfillment of salvation this intriguing
documentary hosted by pastor Doug
Batchelor explores the most striking
bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time get your copy
today available now on DVD blu-ray or
USB for more information visit kingdoms
in time.com dt know amazing facts has a
free bible school that you can do from
the comfort of your own home it includes
27 beautifully illustrated study lessons
to aid in your study of God's Word
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 184 for 257,000 that's
one eight four four two one five 7,000
[Music]
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors 12-part
sermons
you